a lot of people say women are paid less
than men I actually observe how people
behave or women behave versus men behave
and men are more likely to ask for a pay
rise because they're more confident to
ask for more money women naturally have
a maternal Instinct so they're often
open to doing things for free because
it's a maternal Instinct I'll look after
you I'll do that don't worry about it
without asking for more pay a lot of men
would not do that for free so I do think
there are certain traits in men or women
that mean that men do get more money
than women so I guess one thing that I
like to do is tell women about that if
you can make them aware of it by the way
that guy over there he wouldn't have
done that for free he would have said
you could pay me another 50 Quid or
whatever if I can let women know that
then like oh I didn't realize someone
else would ask for money for that like
I'm happy to do it for free and I'm like
no no so you've got to accept those
examples but I do see also the traits
that I see in women and men and how men
are more confident to go wait you want
more from me yeah you can pay me more
money